there's an there's another strange
element to that which is that on the one
hand the the radical feminist types the
neo-marxist postmodernists are are very
much opposed to the patriarchy let's say
and that's that uni-dimensional
ideological representation is perhaps
the word can be applied to Republican
Rome and that's it okay well and maybe
it could be applied usefully to certain
kinds of tyranny but not to a society
that's actually functional Victorian
England was arguably okay but other than
that did you use the word patriarchy in
that in a slapdash way so am a tourist
absolutely absolutely you know just
shows people know nothing about history
whatever having ever it had done no
reading so and so what confuses me about
that is that despite the fact that the
patriarchy is viewed as this essentially
evil entity and that that's associated
with the masculine energy that built
this oppressive structure the antithesis
of that which would actually be
femininity as far as I can tell which is
tightly associated with care and with
child-rearing is also denigrated so it's
like the only proper rule for women to
adopt is a patriarchal rule despite the
fact that the patriarchy is something
that's entirely corrupt so the
hypothesis seems to be that the
patriarchy would be just fine if women
ran it so no changes it's just that it
would just be a transformation of
leadership and somehow that would that
would rectify the fundamental problem
even though it's hypothetically supposed
to be structural